What's up guys!
We are Pongfinity
So a few weeks ago
we asked for your challenge ideas on Instagram
And today we will be
trying them out
Let's see what you came up with!
This episode is sponsored
by NordVPN.
They have a great VPN offer for you
which we will talk more about later on.
But now to the challenges!
You were not even trying to get that on the table!
I was!
This makes no sense!
There is a reason why there is a net in table tennis.
Emil: It looks like something else than table tennis...
Your side?
He went for it!
It went a bit out of hand maybe...
I think it's time to go to the next challenge!
It's time to turn the table upside-down!
There we go!
This is going to be so difficult!
It doesn't really bounce so well
This is not the easiest challenge!
Whose point was that?
My point?
It touched
No, it didn't!
The world's fastest upside-down table
serve!
Left hand, right hand, between the legs
Around the net shots
Let's go!
Okay, first let's use this as a racket.
This is good exercise!
That's why it's
called exercise ball.
That's true!
This is actually the original purpose of an
exercise ball
This is what they don't tell you in the manual
but this is how
you actually should use it
I can't believe that actually worked
What are you doing?
I don't know!
I have got a new approach
to this one
Over! How did I get it over?
Jackpot!
I did a jackpot onto myself...
It's the new ITTF approved ball
40++++
Lucky point!
So guys you have wanted us to play with the bottom part of the racket
So here we go!
Roller!
Okay, now more about NordVPN
who is sponsoring this episode
NordVPN is offering a 70% discount
On a 3 year plan.
Go to NordVPN.com/Pongfinity
And if you use the promotion code: pongfinity
You will get an additional 1 month for free.
For those who don't know what a VPN is
It stands for Virtual Private Network
And essentially that means
it allows you to access websites and online services privately and securely
So basically when you are browsing online
your information is jumping around the Internet just like this ball
And someone camp jump in to intercept it
But if you are using NordVPN
Your information is encrypted
So it travels through a VPN server
To whichever website you are connecting to
Which basically makes it a lot more difficult for anybody to intercept your information
NordVPN has thousands of servers all around the world
Which helps keep servers really fast wherever you are
If you travel a lot and use a lot public Wi-Fi
For example hotel Wi-Fi, airport Wi-Fi
It's really useful to have a VPN
And since some videos are not available in all countries
With NordVPN you can watch Pongfinity videos all over the world!
So go check out the offer at NordVPN.com/pongfinity
And big thanks to NordVPN for sponsoring this video!
Until next time!